Donald Trump's endorsement has failed once
again to get a Republican elected in a very
red state because with 51.3% of the vote incumbent
democratic Louisiana governor John Bel Edwards
has been reelected, defeating the Republican
challenger Eddie risk pony or Riz penny.
I'm not exactly sure how it's pronounced.
Winning by roughly 40,000 votes or about 2.5
percentage points.
There are many reasons why this is an interesting
race.
Um, we will talk about, uh, a variety of them
here.
Number one is that again, this is a red state.
This is a red state that we'll have a democratic
governor now who could, could depends what
happens in 2020 overlap with a democratic
president depending on what happens in November
and might actually be able to do some good
things and maybe move Louisiana to the left.
But we will have to think about whether John
Bel Edwards is actually the type of Democrat
that wants to move Louisiana to the left.
And I'll get to that later.
But just as importantly as we head towards
2020 is the consideration of the Trump effect.
This is another Republican in Louisiana who
association with Trump, who's rallying with
Trump, whose endorsement from Trump didn't
get him the victory even in a very red state.
So we are very quickly learning that red state
governors may be worse off with Donald Trump's
endorsement, which Eddie risk Bonnie had.
So two important things here.
Number one, do not let Trump now revise history
by pretending that he wasn't heavily promoting
the Republican challenger because Trump went
to Louisiana, he rallied for the Republican.
Trump was very involved and Trump just lost
on this one.
Now on the other hand, it is really important,
and I alluded to this before to understand
that John Bel Edwards, the incumbent now reelected
governor in Louisiana.
This is not a progressive Democrat or even
anything remotely close to approximating a
progressive Democrat.
John Bel Edwards is against abortion.
John Bel Edwards is for more guns and more
places.
John Bel Edwards signed a crazy restrictive
anti-abortion bill this year in Louisiana.
So in a sense, winning by 2.5 percentage points
against the ha.
A candidate that had Trump support is not
as notable as it would be if this were an
actual progressive, because John Bel Edwards
is no progressive.
This is about as centrist or even right wing
as a Democrat ever.
Really is.
And we could, you know, talk about Joe mansion,
who's the democratic Senator from West Virginia,
who is the most conservative Democrat in the
Senate.
Maybe John Bel Edwards is even more to the
right of Joe mansion.
You could probably make a strong case of that.
We'd have to look issue by issue, but a loss
is a loss for Donald Trump.
And that's really the issue as we go forward
and endorsement from Donald Trump's support
from Donald Trump, Trump rallying with you,
it's not enough even to get you a win in many
red States.
And that could affect not only Donald Trump
in 2020, it could might be a signal about
Trump's 2020 reelection attempt.
But it could also be interesting in terms
of the key Republican senators that we are
trying to push out in 2020 a few weeks ago,
I told you that although I still think it
is unlikely that Democrats take the Senate
in 2020, I think it's more likely in 2022
I did revise, uh, the strength of that statement.
I do believe that there is a path to Democrats
taking the Senate in 2020 and one of the things
that would very much help Democrats take the
Senate in 2020 is if Donald Trump's support
becomes increasingly toxic and will continue
to follow that.
The other funny thing about this is how Republicans
have just wound themselves into a knot around
this Louis Louisiana gubernatorial race.
They were confident going in because like
I said, Louisiana is very red.
And before the election, many of these Trumpists
were saying, this is going to show you the
power of Trump.
This win, this, uh, removal of the incumbent
democratic governor by Eddie Russ spinny respond,
I wish I knew how to pronounce it, uh, is
going to show you how Donald Trump is very,
very strong.
His endorsement, his support, they're going
to knock out the incumbent democratic governor.
They lost and now that they lost, they are
pretending Trump was never really that involved.
And anyway, this guy was a bad candidate.
It's not Trump's fault.
This has nothing to do with Trump whatsoever.
Trump flew there and held his crazy nationalist
rallies mostly of course, to feed his own
ego.
They, they, I don't know that it was really
to take out the democratic governor.
It was probably because Trump wanted to get
in front of a crowd that, uh, wa was once
again handpicked Brown nosers because it ended
very poorly for him when he went to the world
series game.
When he went to the UFC match, he wanted one
of these crazy sycophantic crowds, but it
did not ultimately help the Republican wins.
So that's going to be a super interesting
narrative to follow into the 2020 elections
and we will be following it for sure.
Let me know what you think about this.
A reply on YouTube, if you are watching on
YouTube, send me a tweet at the Pacman.
If you are on Twitter, I will remind you on
black Friday I think or Thanksgiving day,
we are going to be sending out an email with
the last major membership drive of 2019 if
you've been thinking about becoming a member
and supporting the show, but you want to do
it at a massive discount, get on our newsletter
by going to David pakman.com many hundreds
of you have done this since I mentioned it
last week.
Sign up and then on Thanksgiving day or black
Friday you will get an email which will say
this is the coupon code you were waiting for.
It will be a beautiful, glorious thing that
I
can assure you.
I'll get on the newsletter.
We will take a quick break and be back right
after
this very, very
busy
news weekend.